(musique traditionnelle russe)
- Les effets de la guerre
en Ukraine sont bien
visibles à Paris.
Les réfugiés ukrainiens arborent
bleu. Les Russes qui ont fui,
eux, sont plus discrets.
Comme Taisiya et Vasily,
avec leur fille de 5 ans en mars
dernier, quelques semaines après
le début de l'invasion russe.
- Je passais à mon conjoint
et je sais qu'il ne veut pas
tuer les Ukrainiens et les
Ukrainiennes. Il ne voulait pas
tuer d'aut
devenus des cibles du régime.
Les deux sont cinéastes
militants, plusieurs fois
arrêtés par la police russe
faire la guerre. Le peuple enRue
sa maison. C'est tout, s'il n'y
a pas de repas chaque jour.
- Ils ont travaillé aux côtés
de l'ONG russe Memor l l l l l a
paix, qui les a d'ailleurs
aidés à fuir.
Ils ont d'abord été hébergés
avant d'emménager dans un hôtel
parisien, grcece à des groupes
de soutien.
sera comme la Corée du Nord,
et pas de manifestations.
- Des dizaines de milliers de
citoyens russes ont commencéeses
hostilités, mais l'exode
s'est intensifié avec l'annonce
de la mobilisation partielle,
le 2
- Nous sommes arrivés ici...
- Ces deux hommes sont arrivés
en France il y a quelques jours.
universitaire en sciences
sociales, l'autr
est psychanalyste à Moscou.
Ils étaient opposés à cette
enrôlés contre leur gré.
Ilnene souhaitent pas être
identifiés, pour protéger
leurs proches restés en Russie.
- Et mon père, une personne très
réréservée, qui n'a jamais dit
quelque chose pareil.
Il a dit : "Tu dois quitter. i .
- Je veux faire quelque chose
le discours de la guerre,
qui va contre la logique
destructive de l'État
- Pour eux, l'enlisement
du régime dans la violence et le
Ils se disent bien accueillis
en France, n'ont pas ressei la
russophobie présente en Europe.
- Les gens qui, peut-être,
supportaient la guerre avant,
la mobilisation. Je veux dire
une chose évidente :elelui
qui veut fuir maintenant,
il ne devient pas en autant
un soldat de Poutine. S'il
veut fuir, il faut l'aider.
- C'est ça. Depuis...
- C'est aussi le point de vue de
l'ONG française Russie libertés.
OLGA PROKOdededededededededededr
des gens qui n'osent pas aller
manifester parce qu'on sait que,
en allant manifester, ils
auront... Ils ri
20 ans de prison, aujourd'hui.
- L'exode est difficile à
quantifier
Frontex évoque le chiffre
d'un million de Russes
qui au
le début de la guerre.
- Ce que nous demandons à l'État
leur accorder un statut spécial.
- Les ressortissants russes que
demandé le statut de réfugié,
en France, parce qu'ils seraient
forcés d'attendre au moins 5 ans
- Maintenant, c'est une
caricature horrible.
C'est l'enfer.
de la Russie soit aujourd'hui
simplement associée à celle
d'un homme : Vladimir Poutine.
et en culture, disent-ils.
Il ne faut pas l'oublier.
- Et c'est ce qui, malgré
en Russie.
(rire)mamamamamamamamamamamamams
à la Russie, c'est comme
le trauma, pour moi.
(musique traditionnelle russ